the question if men do would you agree
men do value fertility
[Music]
like in general men prefer younger women
yeah yeah yeah so what age do you think
it's over
when when would you qualify women as
leftover because at some point like the
guys aren't lining up for girls at 75
right
so so at some point it ends right where
where would you pinpoint that
and i'm curious for you why don't you
guys all give your answers so when you
start
okay
first of all
um
you know oh to be 21
but
at 21 by the time you reach 45
what have you been doing like say 20. we
start our relationships what did we say
speaking to the mic oh sorry brother
[Laughter]
why did i have to be the first to do
that
but yeah so you start your relationships
from like 16
16 to 35.
all them years what have you been doing
you've had ups you've had downs
going back to what you say by then
there's issues there's trauma there's
you know
you're
you're
you've been through a lot you've got
certain guards up because you've been
hurt in certain ways you're seeing
similar traits in partners that you saw
in somebody else that's why when i say
at 35
if i if i see you at 35 i'll be able to
recognize
okay this has happened to you that's
happened to you you've put this time
frame on that i don't want to do this
until then and at 35 what's that
geriatric pregnancy so it's high risk
high risk pregnancy so
for men
we have babies until the end of time for
you
from 35 it gets risky it does
so you can say ah you know
if i'm single today which i'm not
but if i was
i'm
i've got a goal down the spectrum
because i don't want that risk why am i
going to have a risk or you're 35 you're
gonna have certain baggage
because we all got baggage so but
you know by then it's other people's
stuff that's coming into my relationship
and guess what i don't want it
so by 35 you need to be more or less
in your stride with someone even if it's
not marriage
even if it's not marriage you shouldn't
be on the market at 35
so i'm not saying you have to be married
but i'm saying you need to be clearly
off the market
but
would you think
um
so
i'm not too sure like
i wouldn't class people being that's
over 35 as a leftovers that's i feel
like that's a bit of a
kind of
a return but um
i feel like
regardless regardless of the age
you're still gonna have like
you're still gonna go through [ __ ] like
in life you're always gonna go through
stuff
me personally i would like for me to be
like in a stable relationship which i
don't feel like i'm ready for right now
i'd want to be like
stable with myself like mentally like
and before i bring that to someone else
because like if i'm in a relationship
with someone and it's now becoming a and
i come with my baggage that's gonna
cause issues in a relationship if i'm
not secure
um in terms of
the age i would consider
i don't know
i don't really know because then like
like you said people that are like 70
plus years old no one's really
i mean very few probably but like
i don't know and then at the same time
as well you we did say like looks kind
of
you start with like yeah
there's people that are 35 that don't
look favor
there is that so one side no okay just
one quick question have you you've been
in a relationship before yeah yeah
and it's affected you
not i'm not saying negative or positive
i'm just saying this affected you it's
changed the course of why you've decided
i'm just finding me i'm doing this so 15
years of that
i find you in 15 years time have gone
through that
all right let's say
three or four times
that's
nobody really wants
what you're gonna come with
because you would have done it many
times
and you haven't figured it out
you haven't self-diagnosed yourself and
found out what what you need to do so
that's why i say at 35 it's different
when you're young
you know but if you keep
and i'm not i'm not saying this to you
we're just having a conversation but um
just in general if you keep doing the
same thing and getting the same outcome
by the time
we meet
i'm 40 you're 35 i'll be like
this
four times and i'm saying four times
because i'm being respectful
i'm saying four times because i'm being
respectful yeah can i just say that
you're saying about 35
but if you are young wouldn't it be
easier to be in a stable relationship
get married when you're young when you
haven't got that trauma yes you haven't
got that experience so as far as i'm
concerned the younger you can get
married the better because you're saying
like oh you've got you've got to do this
you might have to do travelling you
might have to do this you have to do
that you have to do this and do that by
the time you're 35
who wants you you've done everything who
wants you
you've got to feature yourself
you're looking at all these stars
but what have you got to offer a man at
35 when you've been for everything
you've done everything you've got all
this history behind you you've got all
this trauma wouldn't it be easier while
you're young
to get your head together and just say
right but i'm going to find someone same
level as me i'm going to get married the
early the better no trauma
both enjoy the experiences together
learn together grow together by the time
you're 35 you've done everything and
a man's gonna look at you and think what
am i doing with her when i can go and
get somebody younger
okay so i feel like i have a lot of
problems with a lot of things you said
one thing is you kind of made the
assumption that um
you don't have you won't you can't get
trauma from a marriage like he said one
a positive from marrying early is that
you don't have trauma you can have
trauma from your childhood
like i wouldn't say that you should just
equate being young with not necessarily
having any problems haven't experienced
life um and another thing i would say is
again i feel like marriage is a huge
commitment that shouldn't be undermined
like once you've married someone you're
committed to them like what they want if
they wake up tomorrow and they decide
they want to move across the world that
impacts you
and those kind of things those
tendencies are more likely to happen
when you're young
and you don't really you're still trying
to figure out life
so i would agree i would disagree with
oh you should
aim to marry early
so i have a question do you think that
what do you think is more traumatizing
one partner or
what would you say the average body
count well i was being generous yeah
okay
so so so let's say like by like 35 right
how many partners would that girl have
had over the years like what's what's
more traumatizing one
or
okay so this is another problem you
can't equate someone's quality and who
they are to their body count right so so
this is this is a common misconception
that a lot of girls have and the reason
you can is because if a girl's a virgin
on her wedding night she has an 80
chance of a happy marriage if she sleeps
with five or more guys it goes down to
25 percent